>> GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS MORE
INFURIATING THAN BEING LIED TO
BY YOUR OWN GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNMENT YOU PAY FOR, THE
ONE YOUR ANCESTORS RISK THEIR
LIVES TO PROTECT.
DOES THAT HAPPEN TO YOU?
OF COURSE IT HAS.
IT ENRAGES YOU.
BUT IF IT HAPPENS OFTEN ENOUGH,
IF YOUR GOVERNMENT MAKES A HABIT
OF LYING TO YOU, THEN OVER TIME
IT BECOMES SOMETHING ELSE.
OVER TIME YOU REALIZE YOU'RE NOT
REALLY LIVING IN A DEMOCRACY.
YOU CAN'T BE.
BECAUSE IN A DEMOCRACY, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS A MORAL AND LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO TELL YOU THE
TRUTH, ALWAYS.
PERIOD.
AND THAT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE IN
A DEMOCRACY, YOU ARE NOT A
SUBJECT OR A MERE CONSUMER,
YOU'RE A CITIZEN.
YOU ARE A SHAREHOLDER IN THE
SYSTEM.
YOU ARE AN OWNER OF IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN YOUR
GOVERNMENT ARE YOUR EMPLOYEES.
THEY'RE LIKE YOUR CLEANING LADY.
YOU MAY APPRECIATE THE WORK THEY
DO, GOOD JOB, BUT THE MINUTE YOU
CATCH THEM STEALING YOUR CUFF
LINKS, YOU FIRE THEM.  THOSE ARE
THE RULES BECAUSE IT'S YOUR
HOUSE, NOT THEIRS.
BUT WHAT IF THE RULES WERE
INVERTED?
WHAT IF YOU CAUGHT AN EMPLOYEE
STEALING BUT INSTEAD OF SEEMING
ASHAMED AND PEN TANT, HE RIPPED
AROUND AND ATTACKED YOU LIKE YOU
WERE THE CRIMINAL?
WELL, THAT IS THE EXPERIENCE OF
WATCHING WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN
JOHN KIRBY TALKING ABOUT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINES.
ANYONE WHO THINK THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN ANY WAY
INVOLVED WITH THAT SABOTAGE,
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY, IS NOT
SIMPLY WRONG, NO.
ANYONE WHO IMAGINES THAT IS A
BAD PERSON.
A TOOL OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WATCH.
>> DID THE U.S. OR A PROXY FOR
THE U.S. HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE EXPLOSION ON THE NORTH
STREAM PIPELINE?
>> UNITED STATES HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT.
IT'S JUST RAUSH PROPAGANDA IT
AND DISINFORMATION.
NOW WE KNOW IT WAS AN ACTIVE
SABOTAGE, BUT THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATION GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
INTO -- INTO CREDENTIALING THAT
IN TERMS OF, YOU KNOW, WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE.
WE'RE GOING TO LET THE
INVESTIGATORS TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT, BUT CLEARLY THIS WAS AN
ACT OF SABOTAGE.
>> SO YOU CAN OFFICIALLY SAY
THAT THE U.S. WAS NOT INVOLVED
IN ANY WAY IN THIS ATTACK?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT.
>> NOT TO BELABOR THIS, BUT FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY WHY WOULD RUSSIA ATTACK ITS
OWN PIPELINE.
THAT CREATES LEVERAGE THE WEST.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> AGAIN, I CAN'T SPEAK TO
SPECIFIC ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS
ACTIVE SABOTAGE.
I JUST ASSURE YOU THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
OF COURSE, THAT'S JUST RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
>> SO NOTICE THE QUESTION.
DID THE U.S. -- DID THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OR ANY OF ITS
PROXIES HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE SABOTAGE.
JOHN KIRBY SAID WE DIDN'T DO IT
AND MOVES RIGHT TO THE POINT
WHICH IS SAYS ANYONE WHO SAYS WE
DID IT IS REPEATING RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
THAT'S WHAT JOHN KIRBY SAYS.
THAT'S DISINFORMATION.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
ONLY TRULY BAD PEOPLE SAY.
OKAY.
IF THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS, SO
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO BELIEVE IT.
BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO WONDER, NO
ONE DOES BELIEVE THAT.
WHY?
WHERE MIGHT SOME AMERICANS HAVE
GOTTEN THE NOTION THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED, DIRECTLY OR THROUGH A
PROXY, IN THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
NORTH STREAM PIPELINE?
WHY WOULD THEY THINK THAT?
THEY CERTAINLY DIDN'T WATCH IT
ON RUSSIA TODAY.
THEY DIDN'T HEAR IT FROM PUTIN
OR ANY OF HIS MINISTERS.
OF COURSE, ANY BOOK SYMPATHETIC
TO PUTIN HAS BEEN BANNED ON
AMAZON.
HE HAVE PIECE THAT REFLECTION
THE RUSSIAN MODERN POINT OF VIEW
HAVE BEEN CENSORED IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SO ACTUALLY IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, IF AMERICANS ARE DELUDED
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO THE NORTH
STREAM PIPELINE, THE DELUSION
DIDN'T COME FROM MOSCOW 'CAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY FOREMOST COULD
YOU TO GIVE US DISINFORMATION TO
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT HAVE BLOCKED IT,
LONG WITH THE TECH COMPANY.
SO WHERE DID THAT IDEA COME
FROM?
WELL, MAYBE THEY LEARNED FROM
BIDEN HIMSELF.
HE'S BIDEN THIS WINTER ON
AMERICAN TELEVISION PLEDGING TO
DESTROY THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE IF RUSSIA DOES
SOMETHING HE DOESN'T WANT THEM
TO DO.
>> IF RAUSH RUSSIA INVADES,
AGAIN, THERE WILL BE -- THERE
WILL BE NO LONGER A NORTH
STREAM.
WE WILL BRING AN END TO IT.
>> HOW WOULD YOU -- HOW WILL YOU
DO THAT EXACTLY  SINCE THE
PROJECT IS WITHIN GERMANY'
CONTROL?
>> WE WILL -- I PROMISE YOU
WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO IT.
>> SO THAT'S ABOUT AS CLEAR AS
IT GETS.
BIDEN DOESN'T SAY WE WILL SHUT
IT DOWN.
HE SAY THERE WILL BE NO NORTH
STREAM PIPELINE.
WE WILL PUT AN END TO IT.
AND THE REPORTER SAYS, WAIT A
SECOND, IT'S NOT YOUR PIPELINE.
HOW WILL YOU BE ABLE TO DO THAT?
SO HE HAS A CHANCE TO REFRAIN
THE QUESTION, TO REVISE HIS
ANSWER, BUT HE DOESN'T.
HE SAYS, I PROMISE YOU WE'LL BE
ABLE TO TAKE OUT NORTH STREAM.
JOE BIDEN, PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SO THERE'S THAT CLUE.
AND THEN AS IF THAT WASN'T
ENOUGH, LAST WEEK, LAST FRIDAY,
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BRAGGED
ABOUT HOW GREAT THE SABOTAGE OF
NORTH STREAM WAS.
AND WE'RE QUOTING.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY,
SAID TONY BLINKEN.
IT'S A GREAT THING.
NOT A TRAGEDY, A VICTORY.
SOMETHING WE'RE IN FAVOR.
WE'RE EXCITE BESIDE IT.
DESTROYED A NATURAL GAS
PIPELINE.
WE'RE FOR THAT.
SO THAT MIGHT BE ANOTHER CLUE.
DID THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION MAY
HAVE HAD SOMETHING TO DO WITH
IT.
OH, BUT NO SAYS THE WHITE HOUSE.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE
PROMISED WE WOULD DO IT AND THEN
WE QUOTE ABOUT HOW GREAT IT WAS
AFTER IT HAPPENED, WE HAD
NOTHING AT ALL TO DO WITH IT.
WHO DID IT?
WELL, RUSSIA DID IT.
THEY BLEW UP THEIR OWN PIPELINE,
MAKING THEIR OWN COUNTRY POORER
AND WEAKER IN THE MIDDLE OF A
MAJOR WAR BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
CRAZY THE RUSSIANS ARE.
SUICIDAL?
BRILLIANT.
AND IF YOU DON'T BUY THAT STORY,
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW EXACTLY THAT MIGHT WORK,
YOU'RE A DISLOYAL AMERICAN.
SHUT UP.
HERE'S CHRIS STEWART MAKING THE
VERY STATEMENT POINT.
>> JOHN KIRBY WITH THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL WAS ON EARLIER
IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS SAID THE
U.S. WAS NOT BEHIND AND A PROXY
OF THE U.S. WAS NOT BEHIND THE
EXPLOSION IN THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, BOTH OF
YOU, YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS THE LAST THING THAT WE
WANT TO RAISE GAS PRICES FURTHER
IN EUROPE.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THIS IS A
RUSSIAN SABOTAGE OPERATION.
>> AND WHY WOULD RUSSIA DO THAT
ON ITS OWN PIPELINE, WHAT DO YOU
SAY?
>> WELL, THEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUGGESTING THE U.S., THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
WANTS.
>> IT'S JUST SO GREAT.
I MEAN, IT'S PERFECTLY
BIPARTISAN.
HERE YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN FROM
UTAH, CHRIS STEWART, AND A
DEMOCRAT FROM MASSACHUSETTS,
SETH MOLTEN AGREEING PRECISELY.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
WANTS.
HE WANTS YOU TO BLAME THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR SOMETHING HE
DID.
THAT'S THE BIPARTISAN VIEW IN
WASHINGTON.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW THAT.
THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT
THAT'S TRUE.
BRIEFERS FROM THE INTEL AGENCIES
HAVE, AS OF THIS AFTERNOON, TOLD
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHO COMMITTED INDUSTRIAL
TERRORISM AGAINST THESE
PIPELINES.
THAT ITSELF IS A LIE, OF COURSE.
THE CIA HAS NO IDEA AT ALL?
RIGHT.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT AS FAR AS MEMBERS OF THE
CONGRESS, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
EITHER WAY.
THEY HAVE NO FACTS.
THAT IS A FACT, THEY HAVE NO
FACTS.
SO, AGAIN, AS A FACTUAL MATTER,
NEITHER OF THOSE GUYS NOR MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, NO MATTER WHAT
ECONOMY THEY SIT ON A --
COMMITTEE THEY SIT ON HAS NO
IDEA WHO DID IT IF.
IF YOU SUGGEST THAT, YOU'RE
EVIL.
AND THEN THEY GO FARTHER AND SAY
THINGS THAT ARE LIKE COMPLETELY
UNPLAUSIBLE.
THE LAST THING WE WANT IS TO
RAISE GAS PRICES IN EUROPE.
REALLY, SETH MOLTEN.
IS THAT TRUE?
BECAUSE ISN'T THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PHILOSOPHICAL
OPPOSED TO LOW GAS PRICES?
ARE NOT THEY OPPOSED TO ALL
FOSSIL FUELS?
RIGHT.
THEY ARE.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
IS THAT RUSSIA PROPAGANDA?
NO BECAUSE WE CAN'T READ RUSSIA
PROPAGANDA BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
BANNED IN FAVOR OF OU
PROPA
SO MAYBE THERE IS A MOTIVE HERE.
MAYBE THERE'S MORE THAT YOU KNOW
ONE MOTIVE.
BUT DON'T ASK BECAUSE, WARNED
THE MEDIA, ASKING OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS IS FORBIDDEN.
WATCH.
>> FOX NEWS HOST TUCKER CARLSON
IS CLAIMING THE UNITED STATES
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LEAK.
>> OTHER THAN PUTIN AND TUCKER
CARLSON, IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS THAT PUTIN
DID THIS HIMSELF.
>> AND TUCKER CARLSON THIS PAST
WEEK ACTUALLY -- ONCE AGAIN,
DIRECTLY REPEATED RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA SUGGESTING IT WAS
SOMEHOW THE UNITED STATES BEHIND
THE ATTACK ON THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE.
HOW REAL IS THAT MOVEMENT?
IS IT GROWING?
>> IT'S RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
HOW DARE THEY.
REALLY.
IS IT REALLY?
PROBABLY.
JUST THOUGHT EXPERIMENT HERE.
A LOT OF AMERICANS WHO DON'T
FEEL ANY ALLEGIANCE WHATSOEVER
TO RUSSIA, DON'T LIKE PUTIN --
WHY WOULD YOU IF YOU'RE AN
AMERICAN.
BUT CARE A LOT OF THEIR OWN
COUNTRY AND THE BEHAVIOR OF
THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT.
SO THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT, AGAIN,
THE ONE THEY PAY FOR, THE ONE
THEY SUPPOSEDLY CONTROL, IS
DOING THINGS CONTRARY TO THEIR
INTEREST AND THEN LYING ABOUT
IT.
MAYBE THEY THINK THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW AND ASK OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS LIKE, ARE YOU LYING?
AND IF YOU'RE NOT LYING, SPEAK
TELL US HOW YOUR STORY, THE ONE
YOU'RE EXPECTING US TO BELIEVE
MAKE SENSE.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT ASKING
QUESTIONS IS A PATRIOTIC DUTY OF
AMERICANS.
SHUT UP.
THAT HELPS PUTIN.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY IT IS.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO QUOTE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
PROMISING TO ELIMINATE THE NORTH
STREAM PIPELINE.
YOUR HONOR NOT ALLOWED TO QUOTE
HIS SECRETARY OF STATE
CELEBRATING THAT SAB TO THE BEST
OF MY KNOWLEDGE.
>> HOW DOES THIS FIT INTO
PUTIN'S PLAYBOOK.
OF COURSE, AS YOU WOULD EXPECT,
RUSSIANS SAY WE'RE NOT DOING
THIS WE'RE GOING TO LAUNCH AN
INVESTIGATION.
BUT COME ON.
>> LOOK, YOU KNOW, THE
INDICATIONS ARE THAT FOUL PLAY
WAS INVOLVED AND THAT IT APPEARS
THAT, YOU KNOW, RUSSIA IS
CERTAINLY THE LIKELIEST SUSPECT
OF THIS.
>> I THINK THIS IS -- IT CLEARLY
AN ACT OF SABOTAGE OF SOME SORT
AND RUSSIA IS CERTAINLY THE MOST
LIKELY SUSPECT.
I THINK THIS MIGHT BE JUST THE
FIRST ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT
MIGHT BE COMING TO -- TOWARD
EUROPE.
>> WHAT PUTIN IS SAYING TO US BY
BLOWING UP HIS PIPELINE IS,
LOOK, I CAN BLOW UP A PIPELINE
IF NEED BE.
I CAN BLOW UP THE INTERNET
CABLES COMING TO YOUR COUNTRY.
I CAN BLOW UP PEEP LINE.
I CAN DO ALL SORTS OF STUFF.
>> IT'S BILL BROAD PER.
>> DON'T BELIEVE YOUR OWN
LYINGIZE.
>> THERE WAS A MOMENT AFTER THE
WARN IN ANYWAY WAY.
IN FACT HURTING THE NEW YORK
TIMES PLAY IN CONVINCING THE
PUBLIC WHEN HE DIDN'T.
AND FOR THAT ONE MOMENT YOU
THOUGHT, WOW, MAYBE THEY'RE
LEARNING SOMETHING.
MAYBE THEY WON'T DO IT AGAIN.
BUT IT TURNSOUT THE OPPOSITE
HAPPENED.
NOW THEY'RE JUST COMPLETELY
DOUBLING DOWN ON WHAT'S VERY
OBVIOUSLY A LIE AND ATTACKING
ANYONE WHO ASK TO HEAR IT
EXPLAIN RATIONALLY.
AND SUCH AS THE MEDIA, BY THE
WAY.
DC THINK TANKS WHOSE PURPOSES --
WHAT'S THE POINT OF A D.C. THINK
TANK?
TO BOLSTER THE REGIME.
THE BROOKING INSTITUTION FILLED
THAT ROLE FOR MANY YEARS.
THEY PRODUCED THIS ANALYSIS,
QUOTE, U.S. PODCASTERS SPREAD
KREMLIN NARRATIVES ON NORTH
STREAM SABOTAGE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
ANALYSIS IS THAT NOWHERE IN IT
DOES THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTION
REBUT THE EVIDENCE THAT THE U.S.
OR A PROXY OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE SOMETHING TO
DO IT.
IN FACT, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
EITHER WAY.
INSTEAD, THEY JUST ASK ANYBODY
QUESTIONS.
THE THEORIES PUSHED BY THESE
PODCAST MIST ALIGN WITH KREMLIN
MESSAGING.
ALIGN WITH KREMLIN MESSAGING.
THEY USED TO BE GUILT BY
ASSOCIATION.
VLADIMIR PUTIN LIKES DOGS.
YOU LIKE DOGS?
WHAT ARE YOU, A RUSSIAN
SYMPATHIZER?
RIGHT.
OKAY.
IT ALINES WITH RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
SO THE POINT IS, IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER OR NOT IT'S TRUE.
IT ALIGNS WITH KREMLIN
MESSAGING, THEREFORE YOU MUST BE
CENSORED.
BUT NOT EVERYBODY GOT THE MEMO.
THERE ARE, TUCKED AWAY, IN THE
DEEP RECESSES OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY A FEW HONEST LIBERAL
STILL LEFT.
MAYBE THEY'VE BEEN, I DON'T
KNOW, IN ST
PROFESSOR OF COLOMBIA.
SO HE WENT ON BLOOMBERG THE
OTHER DAY AND ASKED ABOUT THE
PIPELINE.
HE SAID THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
EVIDENCE THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS INVOLVED.
BUT RATHER THAN FOLLOW UP, THE
ANCHOR REALIZING THAT FORBIDDEN
TOPICS ARE BEING BROACHED, JUST
SHUT DOWN THE SEGMENT.
BUT NOT BEFORE JEFFREY SAX SAID
THIS.
>> THE DESTRUCTION OF THE NORTH
STREAM PIPELINE, WHICH I -- I
WOULD BET WAS A U.S. ACTION,
PERHAPS U.S. AND POLAND.
THIS IS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO STOP THERE.
THAT'S QUITE A STATEMENT AS
WELL.
WHY DO YOU FEEL --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> -- THAT THAT WAS AS U.S.
ACTION?
WHAT EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE OF
THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S
DIRECT RADAR EVIDENCE THAT U.S.
HELICOPTERS, MILITARY
HELICOPTERS THAT ARE NORMALLY
BASED THERE WERE CIRCLING OVER
THIS AREA.
WE ALSO HAD THE THREATS FROM THE
UNITED STATES EARLIER IN THIS
YEAR THAT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER,
WE ARE GOING TO END IN ORDER
STREAM.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOW TO SAY THESE
THINGS IN -- IN THE WEST.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
ALL OVER THE WORLD WHEN I TALK
TO PEOPLE, THEY THINK THE U.S.
--
>> OKAY.
>> -- DID IT.
>> PROFESSOR.
>> BY THE WAY, EVEN REPORTERS ON
OUR PAPERS THAT ARE INVOLVED
TELL ME PRIVATELY, YEAH, WELL OF
COURSE IT DOESN'T SHOW UP IN OUR
MEDIA.
THE ANCHORS IS GETTING CLEARLY
-- STOP HIM.
STOP HIM.
WHAT EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE?
>> WELL, THERE'S RADAR EVIDENCE.
>> WHAT?
BE QUIET.
SHUT UP.
JUST CUT HIM OFF.
NEVER INVITE HIM BACK.
STOP.
THE ONLY EXPLANATION IS THE ONE
THAT GOVERNMENT WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SO EVI